I have 100 minecraft players in this
arena and whichever wanted these
minecraft players is the last man
standing wins $10,000 no joke
alright can you hear me yeah so here's
the thing you guys are all in arena and
whichever one of you is the last one
standing wins $10,000 Oh calm down calm
down
alright so me and Chris are gonna call
together the me and Chris are in
creative mode everyone else is in
survival now Chandler and Cara are also
competing in this challenge so we'll see
if they win I love mr. beast oh my god
is that Chris here Chris how about you
carpet bomb them with some right
and carpet I feel my gosh
people are dying look at all the reefers
car right so my skin is a Steve skin
with a dragon head so they will not
recognize me before you go any further
uh-huh I have a button over here that
allows me to give them swords what are
you gonna start with of course wood of
course
wait take off your head can I have it I
can hold it in my hand
holy crap look at like iron meal in a
world this is boy Jedi and he won
$10,000 in one of our previous videos
and the round is over what you want
Thank You Jedi I'll get you your 10
grass all right know what we got a spawn
some creepers around him because if he
wins 10 grand again everyone's gonna
think we're playing favorites oh my gosh
Jimmy what the heck dude I better die
Chandler I died no way
did you actually yes all coral died what
happened I heard you died what happened
honestly I don't really know it just it
got a bunch of explosions that was
probably the creepers I put right beside
you how did you know who I was you're
gay we can see your name I was trying to
cry but fails I asked him what they
would do with the $10,000 and why
they're all type of licious fathers go
boom alright I asked them a question oh
my god this is me alright and then we
spawned creepers oh he stupid I can't
what I feel so bad I got it I'm sorry
protect me Chris Chandler's building an
army look they're following him they're
all following Chandler Jimmy you're
being unjust I'm doing what's right for
your face oh no don't Bambi I think it's
time we regain authority of this map
they've been gravitating towards corners
and I say screw this corner oh this
corner is gone
oh no no no no no Brian have one of
these I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead okay I got banned
Chandler just died can you please unban
me Jimmy's being a jerk sound like
can you unban me please I beg your
pardon I think you've been unbanned I
gonna band your nerds I'm gonna help
them so much
Chandler operation help the fans hello
Corner yank I come with presents except
me quarter gang let me in your corner
I'm gonna permanently remove all corners
corner Ganga's no more I don't like
their attitude recently oh you want one
you want one
lava all right let's get some more
creepers back on the mat just get your
after the quarter help me
it looks like Carl in Chandler giving
people diamond door oh wait here I'm
gonna give him a side it's minecraft ok
it sounds worse than it is how does this
guy have diamond Armour starting up
there
alright watch this we can turn them all
back into leather armor though do it do
it do it wake it oh wow ha ha take that
Chandler in Carl yeah they're also
giving out crossbows all right someone
needs to tame them Trey hey can you
please ban Carl and Chandler from the
server and under no circumstances let
them come back they're giving people
Diamond armor okay yeah thank you all
right Tracy's gonna ban them okay guys
I'm dropping as many or like an awesome
rack okay last thing I'll do I'm
dropping a dragon head oh and what two
unfair Oh what did you get pan Chandler
wait what I tried that's it what do we
do we got to get new accountant we're
gonna talk to them on Venus on Venus are
you kidding of course we're helping them
I love being unfair trade you have to go
to the bathroom no I'm good
you've been unbanned okay so so far if
you're still alive you're still
competing for 10 grand congratulations
second I'm going to turn on PvP for
exactly one minute you guys don't have
to fight each other but if you want you
can good luck
they're gonna fight each other this she
said we must stand united no fighting
don't be babies fight only cowards but
they must please the Panda guy the Panda
gods
fighting I'm back in are you bitching
let's go I got banned because I'm
helping you guys they don't want me
helping you listen if you guys need to
be gracious with each other okay I'm
throwing a lot arrows yeah they're gonna
ban us again soon and go they can now
fight each other oh wait they're mining
blocks they're mining block stray quick
turn it off boys they weren't supposed
to be able to my box oh we didn't think
this through
stop they're going as quick as possible
alright now they can't break blocks
anymore okay well I'm gonna join the
district Carl Chandler Chris come here
I'm above the human rights house which
is ironic because what we're about to
talk about do you know why I called you
three here no look around there's people
everywhere
yeah we've been recording for like two
hours yeah yeah I'm sweating it's the
time we start eliminating some okay all
right so let's come up with a game plan
what are we doing I don't care how
heinous it is all right you have lava
that's cool
what mobs are we spawning scroll through
find the scariest things you can Carl I
swear to God if you help anyone in any
way I will bris you're in charge of lava
Carla you're in charge of mobs I want
magma cubes and creepers Chandler you're
in charge of bees what end other mobs
and I'm gonna be
T&T said no more helping people I want
this to be over in the next five minutes
I want them dead the message is clear
born ready
born ready break on three three break
all right
the fun is about to begin good luck
buddy I might come close guys so pay
attention to who's left okay
oh no Chandler that's just rude right
five minutes they're gonna die all right
let's see if they can handle it oh boy
Giudice here he's got a gap oh can he
survive y'see oh he's doing a smart boy
play why is this guy swimming how is he
swimming gonna go check in on them on in
the discord why is it so hard to kill
you guys you guys have to let the
armored shouldn't more D be dying miss
least I can help you if you want you
guys tell me how do i you know thin the
numbers how do i do lightning flash
summon lightning even poison smoke do
that oh oh that's a good one thank you I
appreciate you guys helping me kill you
okay boys they said if we gave them
slowness it'd make it a lot harder on
them oh I made super snowballs do they
blow up the map no all right then
hey anyone did you kill a bunch with
those Chris nah I only see like Oh enemy
I see 130 above oh I hit him into the
lava
oh my bad I was testing the snowball I'm
so sorry whoever that was I'm gonna go
test the snowball over here a few
minutes late I'm I'm pushing the withers
down with the snowballs Oh Chris oh I
keep acting out I put a sign that said
follow me or you will die and he was
following me and then he died I was
trying to push the withers all the way
that he died - wait how many people are
left plate this guy right here
keep them boxed in this corner all right
so this is the last corner the three
people left are fairy doctor and
practical and boy Jedi you are the three
people standing and you guys are now
versing each other for 10
that was the most unenthusiastic room
I've ever heard of my life what are you
guys millionaires here's today I don't
know if you guys know this but boy Jed I
actually won $10,000 two days ago what
yeah he won the other one so are you
guys gonna let him win another 10 grand
yes hey doctor impractical how much is
10 grand worth - that's enough to give
me a car Frere how much is it worth to
you
okay well you guys play your hearts out
GG have fun what better way to end this
tournament than a three-way PvP duel
we're going to switch them to survival
and we're gonna let them figure out who
wins anything goes but one of you is
walking away with 10,000 more dollars
than you currently have boy Jedi I
dropped you a little something doctor
impractical I dropped you a little
something for real I dropped you a
little something make do with those 64
creepers yep alright let's see what you
guys bro wins at all my friend just won
$10,000 off of playing minecraft mister
and practical I'm really sorry that uh
things didn't go your way no thank you
alright fine here we're gonna send you a
thousand dollars because I feel kind of
bad oh thank you
Frere you just won $10,000 of what is
going to your mind I honestly don't
believe this how old are you 14 just
gave a 14 year old grand
alright I have no problem with it what
are you gonna use the money on you wanna
give money to my parents we got a little
problem with my gross and probably
saying it that's very noble sounds good
to me
alright we're about to wrap up the video
anything you want to say before we go
took really but but also subscribe to
mr. beast gaming thank you guys so much
for coming out congratulations on
winning ten grand I love you all and
I'll see you in the next video